[Musique]
le monde selon ma mobylette quelque part
dans le sud est de l'asie je vous laisse
deviner où le principe s'est trouvé une
mobylette et partir visiter le pays et
quelque chose me dit
que je devrais pas avoir trop mal à
trouver une mobylette ici
[Musique]
oui mais
je suis leur quartier où on
est il ya des modes de partout j'ai
l'impression il ya surtout du neuf dans
le coin l'action c'est ce genre de
modèle
bon je vais voir
y'a pas
un modèle de deux roues motorisés qui a
était plus vendu que celui là je sais
plus si c'est enfin ses rangs en
dizaines voire en centaines de millions
d'exemplaires que ça a été fait toute
l'asie roule là dessus alors y est celle
non non c'est pas ici je vais faire des
affaires en fait c'est un véritable
cauchemar d'acheter une mobylette ici
parce que y en a tellement que je suis
complètement pot mais c'est pas toi fond
on a pas mal de motos d'occasion en ce
moment
et si j'en achète une j'aurai des
papiers
bien sûr on vous fait les papiers 1
dites moi vous parler vraiment vite
merci beaucoup
dès qu'on sort en fait là hier tous les
petits métiers autour de la mob
un atelier de peinture carrosserie
[Musique]
e
banks et motos à vendre c'est ça veut
dire motocyclettes et cours autant s'y
colle c'est un moteur allez bon 63 53 29
bon bah
je crois que suis en règle
ok c'est parti
ok bail
[Musique]
j'ai acheté cette
en fait une grosse cylindrée le deux
roues
le vendus
toute l'histoire des deux roues
motorisés
lormont selon ma mobylette il c'est
vraiment le moment d'en parler 4
millions de deux roues pour huit
millions d'habitants saigon c'est comme
ça qu'on appelle même si le nom officiel
ministre hâtif certes chi minh ville
homo
selon ma mobylette au vietnam pour un
terrible à peu près 1000 km qui va faire
traverser
le mékong et ensuite je entrée en
passant
la jouer tranquille à seix le tenir je
suis paniqué
alors d'habitude quand j'arrive dans un
nouveau pays j'essaye de comprendre un
peu les règles de circulation alors là
c'est autre chose bages et sai pa
[Musique]
maj
vieux films avec saigon ces vélos c'est
pousse pousse ça a bien changé
[Musique]
en bon chic parisien comme on disait
au chic parisien à l'eau vous avez une
tour eiffel parce que la france ça
représente ça représente quoi pour vous
cet objet vous savez si les vietnamiens
s'habille assis avec un pantalon un peu
à la française c'est à cause de ce
symbole
c'est symbole pour nous ce sont les
français c'est paris
c'est la mode française
et les les jeunes j'ai l'impression
qu'ils portent beaucoup de blue jeans ça
doit vous faire du tort ce
nom ça nous fait pas beaucoup de tort en
fait vous savez ici dont nous aimons
bien mélanger les styles la mode
italienne sas pierre un peu démodé
étrangères par exemple en ce moment elle
est influencée par la mode coréenne
quand les coréens créer un modèle nous
limitons nous nous inspirons aussi du
pantalon à la française et de la
cheville à l'occidentale vous en
conservant la base et nous changerons
seulement quelques détails
[Musique]
c'est le symbole de tous les tailleurs
oui c'est un instinct symbole fort
messieurs tout le monde ne connaît pas
ce symbole ce qu'il signifie vraiment
mais la majorité des tailleurs la
connaissent bien il faut être dans le
métier pour le savoir car la majorité
des tailleurs qui confectionne des
vêtements occidentaux disposent de ce
symbole alors soit il le met sur le col
de la chemise comme une marque soit il
affiche comme publicité à la devanture
de leurs magasins celui ci que vous
voyez ici c'est moi qui les créent de
mes propres mains car j'aime bien
inventer des modèles on les trouve pas
ma commerce on les trouve comme une
marque ou comme une bonne publicité
ap st
essayez une vesse - pour voir si ça me
va vos modèles
comme ça
ah ouais c'est bien très très bien elle
est bien coupé un essai l'hommage à
l'est elle est un peu courte mais sinon
je vous l'aurais prise parce que c'est
vraiment très élégant ça bon ok bah tant
pis bravo
j'adore la couleur
[Musique]
bye
un petit costard à 40 euros
apporter ici au vietnam ça doit être une
souffrance
de retour au pays que jo ratés joly
[Musique]
et
ça marche bien
[Musique]
première région compte
je quitte saigon
faut pas hésiter
ce qui est bien
c'est que je sais que j'aurai jamais
problème d'essence et après un petit
marchand ambulant des gens qui manquent
route ensemble
allez je vais saigon derrière moi je
prends la nationale
j'ai encore tous mes p'tits potes qui
sont là bas
au dessus d'eux
et avec un peu de chance
t aujourd'hui j'ai croisé un des bons
mais quand
mais quand dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
mais là il ya des rizières
et je veux en profiter
dicton du jour quand on parle de riz
plus rire
le cambodian le regard qu'on sait
la hausse tient les coûts de chanter
comprendra qui pourra
est-ce que je peux la laisser là
[Musique]
allô
t'es propriétaire de deux de ses champs
où tu les loups oui je suis propriétaire
cette terre c'est celle de mes ancêtres
e ri c'est quoi c'est là c'est la
nourriture principale pour les
vietnamiens c'est ça vous en mangez à
tous les repas
oui le riz et la nourriture principale
des vietnamiens nous ne pouvons pas nous
en passer
et c'est ça rapporte bien de faire du
riz
les i culteurs c'est pas vraiment un bon
métier car les prix ne sont pas très
stable et le marché plutôt fluctuant on
arrive tout juste à subvenir à nos
besoins
et de manière générale c'est un métier
très dur pour nous les paysans
vietnamiens tu as des enfants oui j'ai
deux enfants et ils vont faire ils vont
faire la riziculture aussi ou alors ils
vont faire autre chose ils font autre
chose
mes enfants sont encore petits pour le
moment ils sont encore à l'école je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils vont devenir mais je
leur souhaite un avenir meilleur que le
mien
j'aimerais qu'il devienne instituteurs
ou médecin
l'économie ne va pas très bien et
j'ignore quel sera l'avenir de mes
enfants mais moi en tant que père
j'espère surtout qu'ils réussiront mieux
que moi qu'ils auront aussi une
meilleure situation que la mienne
t'as pas l'air misérable toi pourtant
mais je suis tout le temps en train de
travailler je suis tout le temps dans
les rizières chez occupé avec le
désherbage la semence la moisson je suis
tout le temps au travail aussi un
costaud mais qu'arrive là vous faites la
riziculture aussi vous êtes chez nono
montre en or tournoi
ouais ça gagne bien
huilé les plus riches il a mieux réussi
que moi
à toi t'as rien toi t'as pas de chaîne
pourquoi il est plus riche que lui parce
qu'il travaille mieux il est plus fort
c'est pour ça
lui travaille la terre mais il est aussi
propriétaire d'une usine de chaussures
c'est pour ça qu'il est plus riche
et vous mettez pas des chaussures vous
êtes en tongs non mais ce dimanche
aujourd'hui je me repose ok
chaud
c'est bon ça et ça va il travaille il
travaille bien le petit
et avant c'était vous qui faisiez qui
travaillaient dans les champs
il ya les trois générations
[Musique]
alors est ce que tu veux cultiver le riz
quand tu seras grand plan
[Musique]
je
où est légal
je voulais c'est juste
[Musique]
comme en cas mon
dieu
[Musique]
on
c'est stressant comme pour buts la route
est pas et pas forcément bonnes
sa plateforme dans tous les sens
énormément de monde
poussière
[Musique]
pause
ces endroits cdd petit café il ya comme
ça au bord de la route un peu partout
pour que les
tous les types en bécane comme moi
puisse s'arrêter en inverse et se
reposer 5 minutes dans un hamac ça
plutôt bien je ferme les yeux
j'ai l'impression que c'est au bord de
l'autoroute je suis au bord de
l'autoroute c'est vraiment nev
mais là où ils sont forts les arbres
sont à 10 11 parfaite juste tombé
et puis ils ont pris bien sur la route
ou faut qu'ils donnent un parasol de
feuilles très fort c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blême on va s'arrêter je vais mettre un
k way
il est balèze le mec il arrive à fumer
sous la pluie
tout le monde est là
les saisons des pluies qui disent
à
il est où le mékong
voilà ça c'est un peu du mékong tout ça
bon de toute façon ça va être beaucoup
de mes comptes parce que le mékong et
serpente au vietnam
note ici l'embarcadère
on la d 106
à technique
j'ai plus de force one
way the rain
vas-y mais la sauce rock
mobylette
le pied marin cette maman
bush pas
[Musique]
je pense que c'est pas la dernière fois
que je vais être sur un bateau ici parce
que le mékong
je vais le traverser à plusieurs
reprises donc il va falloir que je me
mette sur des embarcations
élégant
est ce que tu pourrais habiter ailleurs
que sur le mékong est ce que tu pour
aller habiter dans les terres
non je ne crois pas je ne peux vivre qui
si je suis habitué au mékong et je ne
pourrais vraiment pas vivre ailleurs
oui j'ai toujours habité au bord de
l'eau c'est ma vie ici
tu sais comme je travaille tous les
jours avec mon bateau même s'il ya
beaucoup de trafic ce qui est pratique
sais que je peux me garer très
facilement
oui j'ai une femme et deux enfants un de
neuf ans et un de 18 mois
et à quel âge on apprend à nager
ici on n'apprend pas aux enfants à nager
dès que l'on fait on doit se lancer il y
va et on aura prend pas à nager ils
doivent se débrouiller
bien beaucoup d'enfants qui habite au
bord du fleuve et qui ne savent pas
nager
ceux qui ont peur et qui ne se sentent
pas encore prêt resteront simplement sur
les rives
il ya beaucoup d'accidents justement
avec les enfants ici si jamais les gens
sont blessés comment on fait
oui il ya beaucoup d'accidents mais
surtout pendant les crues mais en temps
normal non heureusement non
et s'il ya des blessés ou si on a besoin
d'un médecin il y en a ici
et aussi des infirmières dans les
comités de quartier et puis il ya des
pharmacies dans les villages
la patate on
j'adore c'est rudimentaire
avec cela
pauli qui vont se renouvelle
quand est ce qu'on est vraiment dans le
boys band
là où ça fait plusieurs
bon ça
ouais c'est ça en fait il ya un siècle
tous les fleuves en france c'est
exactement pareil il ya un trafic comme
ça
regardez bien une gravure des vieilles
photos même de paris et on doit
attention par contre tout le monde
merci
salut
[Musique]
bonne nuit tout le monde
bon c'est une route un peu monotone il
faut bien dire parce que je suis une
route nationale c'est bien il n'y a pas
de village y a pas de campagne village
c'est une succession de maison comme ça
depuis le début ça fait quand même 300
km tous ces deux régions au sud c'est
tout plat ça c'est la première chose que
je voulais dire ce matin ce qui se passe
c'est du bronze et les onze
une pagode
[Musique]
m
mais il faut qu est ce qui se passerait
si soit ici ou là ça va donner la
session
sans assortir
sa scellé
les boues qui hasard du voyage je me
suis arrêté vraiment par hasard il se
passe quelque chose
c'est tombé sur une concession alors je
suis
son parti de la pagode
et là ils vont faire un entraînement
pour une course n'aura lieu que dans 6
jours en fait
cinquante deux rameurs
ils applaudissent comme des malades
parce que c'est leur écoute quoi c'est
l'équipe de leur village ils viennent
supporter ces câbles on va voir l'équipe
locale de foot qui jouent le dimanche au
stade c'est pareil qu'est ce qui se
passe alors aujourd'hui c'est la fête
comme roque la fête du riz et de
l'espoir de la bonne récolte ainsi à une
compétition oui il ya une compétition
une fois par an qui a lu à la pleine
lune de la mi octobre c'est la fête au
come-back bien combien de pagodes en
compétition là bas il ya toutes les facs
de la région intacte à 25 on peut gagner
quelque chose oui on peut gagner deux
médailles d'or aux pagodes elle a déjà
gagné l'or aie aie aie aie aie aie aie
fogari les mecs là
faut y aller qu'est ce qui se passe
cette fois ci c'est la bonne
[Musique]
ça c'est bien ça
c'est drôle parce que j'ai fait mes
charmes de la même couleur
c'est une pagode et c'est aussi une
école de bronze et j'ai demandé à
rencontrer le
le bonze supérieur
qui veut bien me recevoir
on se trouve ici qu'est ce que c'est que
cet endroit qu'est ce que vous y faites
c'est une école aussi de bronze c'est ça
j'ai vu des jeunes vous enseigner aussi
[Musique]
le bond supérieur et le conseil
d'administration ouvre une session
d'enseignement chaque année pour les
aspirants moines de la région et
d'ailleurs
les aspirants viennent d'une vingtaine
de pagode de la région et c'est que
c'est quoi le rôle d'un d'un bon en fait
dans la société
le premier rôle du bronze est de guider
les fidèles que les aider à s'élever
dans la foi bouddhiste à atteindre
l'idéal de disques il est aussi là pour
aider à honorer la piété filiale
respectée les parents qui nous ont donné
la ville enfin quand on moines
bouddhistes on doit appliquer les
préceptes de bouddha pour faire le bien
autour de soi et vous avez choisi le
orange et a une particularité pour le
orange
cette couleur
dida autorise les moines à utiliser le
jaune safran les moines ont aussi le
droit d'utiliser quelques autres
couleurs le noir mais surtout pas le
blanc c'est la couleur du deuil
les moines ne porte que les couleurs
autorisé par bouddha ils n'oseront
jamais porté celles qui ne sont pas
permises
[Musique]
c'est votre chambre
je peux voir 1 1
alors ils habitent ou bond supérieur
c'est là où dormait là et il ya de quoi
faire la fête chez vous un
dixième end et les a appelés ça
ça de la même couleur craint comme ça
toutes les couleurs officielles et vous
c'est ici vous
super
ah bah ouais le bond supérieur il veut
que s'occuper de moi il veut toujours je
mange que je boive commande commande
elle s'occupe bien de moi ça c'est quoi
anne on obtient maintenant il veut me
donner le café pas de khat et ramon
il ya plein de petits trucs away avec
une pile
d'accord on se demande si on se ferait
pas moins de quelques fois c'est pas mal
ok cameron qu'est ce qui se passe encore
à c'est l'heure de manger aller manger
petite participation faut qu'ils
puissent faire des petites courses bien
manger parce qu'il veut bien manger lui
je suis pas comme on s'adresse à un bond
[Musique]
à bientôt
bacongo
[Musique]
quand on enchaîne c'est un peu compliqué
l'habitude ici c'est plutôt de faire des
des mixtures en qu'un petit plat tout le
monde paie aussi un peu partout on me
prend un coup des plats basique à chaque
fois mais c'est consistance est ce qu'il
faut et ce très bon
je
ville de content
qui se trouvent toujours sur le mode
ne lâchera pas je vois
ce qu'on vient de traverser ce sera déjà
une bonne idée
en tout cas mal
il ya trois kilomètres d'embouteillages
c'est pour arriver à un bac et ceux qui
n'ont pas la chance d'être en mode
autres vont mettre à peu près trois
heures pour arriver au bac joli bordel
tout ça
c'est pas le monde qu'elle est là
allez
comme ça
génial
ça c'est hôtel hôtel là ok merci à
l'hôtel
[Musique]
faut savoir encaisser un hôtel à la
musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui c'est qui vous a vendu le disque
grand luxe ce soir
[Musique]
il est 5h30 fait déjà jour je suis très
tôt ce matin ce qu'on entend
sont les informations qui sont diffusées
à la population par haut parleur c'est
comme ça
[Musique]
8h du mat
parti faire un tour au marché flottant
le kanto
pour l'instant c'est un voyage qui se
fait sous le signe de la mobylette et du
bateau
hot coffee à l'époque kofi c'est bien ça
les merdes
c'est pas bon prix
attendez un petit crochet ça c'est bien
ces pratiques la question ok très bien
ben écoute merci c'est vraiment sympa
comme accueil
et sa petite famille
alors à priori ce qui se passe c'est que
ya des petits bateaux et il ya des gros
bateaux alors voilà
les petits bateaux sont souvent des
paysans qui viennent avec leur récolte
pour la vendre au bon bateau les gros
bateaux au son des mandataires en fait
ils restent sur place ils bougent pas
vivent là ce sont des familles avec la
cuisine à l'arrière ils dorment sur
place ils remplissent leurs bateaux et
ensuite si gros bateaux vont revendre à
d'autres petits bateaux qui vont aller
dispatcher ça sur les différents marchés
flottants qu'on peut trouver dans la
région mais le gros bateau quand il est
ras la gueule yvan yvan yvan mais s'ils
ne vont plus alors là comme les fruits
et légumes sont périssables à quelques
fois il est obligé partir pour aller
vendre sa cargaison directement sur des
grosses villes c'est une histoire de
petit bateau est un gros bateau je crois
que j'ai été clair en fait ils affichent
tous le produit à la vente en haut d'un
d'un piqué donc lui il a mis une
pastèque saveurs qu'ils vendent la
pastèque meillonnas conduit des patates
douces ça veut dire on a dâ patates
douces et ainsi de suite si on a une
banane ça veut dire je rends les bananes
qui bat au gros bateau c'est ça c'est
facile à comprendre un marché
vietnamiens
sherbrooke sont
son nom
cac
alors on a l'eau à magnifique c'est chez
toi
ah ouais ok super tu peux être que tu
vas tu réduis seul maintenant j'ai marié
mes trois enfants tu vis avec
oui je me suis séparé de ma femme depuis
une vingtaine d'années à peu près et ma
femme elle sert l'art ya même dans le
quatre enfants il ya beaucoup de
divorces au vietnam oui il y en a pas
mal et de toute façon quand il n'y a
plus d'animaux avec les deux sont
d'accord ils se séparent donc c'est de
l'alcool ou à l'alcool de riz je suis
seul je me sens triste alors je bois je
m'occupe de teach l'envié après jérôme
pineau et pourquoi tu es triste
je n'ai plus de femmes ça me rend triste
alors je vous raconte moi comment se
déroule la journée tu te lèves
après tu vas tu vas travailler après
racontant un peu le déroulement de la
journée jusqu'à la nuit
le matin je fais le bus avec mon bateau
j'emmène des gens maintenant tu vois je
me repose jusqu'au soir quand je suis
seul je m'occupe de mon chez-moi j'écope
mamés jouanno
et commence comment on se retrouve dans
une maison comme ça c'est toi qui l'a
construite oui je vais construite
moi-même en trois jours grâce aux
feuilles de palmier là sur le toit il
fait frais non trois jours
mais qu'est ce que tu était énervé ou
quoi a la roma
le frein
toi tu bois de l'alcool de riz
[Rires]
[Musique]
qui colle un petit coup une syncope et
regard des combats de coqs
[Applaudissements]
wasquehal je ne parie pas sur les
combats de coqs mais j'aime bien les
regarder
montre
[Musique]
la petite chambre tu as tout ce qui fait
les toilettes c'est direct pour les
poissons ok ambiance ici
you take care of the best ok
extrême et tout doux je les adore
je vais arrêter un peu mon parcours
nautique de toute façon je vais
recroiser le mékong plus tard je vais
essayer de prendre la route dès cet
après midi si le temps me le permet
c'est pas gagné
allez vous me l'avez ou même moule
[Musique]
petite pause bon moi je suis dans un
état lamentable
[Musique]
blanc on sait pas ce qu'ils rien
il avait mangé arrêt d'empotage
c'est bon
et comment vous allez cuisine et
on va faire un potage ou on peut en
faire de l'alcool aussi
jean leur petite tortue leur chair bon
et bien bon appétit bon appétit rien
allez au revoir
c'est bien mon business
[Musique]
bon allez ça s'est calmé
une petite soupe ça te manger ici c'est
nourrissant il faut faire beaucoup de
bruit quand on la mange
allez je reprends la route et je devrais
arriver en fin de journée dans un
village de maisons flottantes et ça j'ai
bien envie d'aller voir donc j'y vais
[Musique]
réf
maintenant
[Musique]
aller retour sur le mékong
j'étais pas monté dans un bateau
ça fait du bien à venir soro
un truc à faire sur la sonorisation des
moteurs
ségo j'attends
pour moi c'est un rêve de gamin
j'avais des amis c'est sûr j'en ai déjà
vu à la télé quand j'étais gamin et
s'ils allaient à l'école en bateau
la plupart des habitants vivent de
l'élevage du poisson économies
principales de la région
alors
quoique
qu'est ce que vous leur donnez à manger
je leur donne à manger de la pâte faite
à partir de poissons mère broyer
disons d un peu les têtes de les têtes
de serpent
combien de poissons seraient là dedans
tu
vas te plaît 30 mines est ce que cette
technique d'élevage existe depuis
longtemps et depuis longtemps depuis la
fin de la guerre du vietnam en 75
[Applaudissements]
et vous les vendez acquis les poissons
ensuite
gens vont principalement aux
particuliers
asseyons hanoi
et tous les gens dans le village ils
font tous la même la même activité
non il ya une maison sur dix qui
pratiquent la pisciculture les autres
font des habitations
c'est quoi comme type de poisson ça
ressemble un peu une anguille et coûte
cher ce poisson et la main des poissons
comme ça on les vend ici sur lieu de
l'élevage à 40000 dôngs le kilo peu
moins de deux euros le kilo à ces essais
assez rapporte bien
c'est correct mais on ne fait pas
souvent de bénéfices il nous arrive de
travailler à perte
bon appétit
donc en fait
cette bouillie qui donne est fait à
partir de tête et de que de sardines
qu'ils achètent à des sardines riz et
ensuite ils en font cette bouillie qui
donne à manger alors poisson à tête de
serpent
barret ta gueule
tkt
[Musique]
tettey
j'ai pris une barque pompon promener
dans village et le batelier vit lui-même
dans ce village dont il m'a invité à
visiter sa maison
en agressant à son tout toutes les
maisons sont faites
de la construit de la même manière donc
il ya le salon la pièce principale comme
dans toutes les maisons d'ailleurs au
vietnam dans là où on accueille les gens
ensuite ici il ya la chambre comme ça le
petit bébé là c'est un coin frigidaire
rangement gillet sauvetage d'ici c'est
quoi ici qu'est ce qui se passe à
les rangements
et puis le cuisant
c'est que ça
donc ça c'est intéressant on voit qu'en
fait toutes ces maisons sont fait poser
sur des sur des embarcations sur des
bateaux mais c'est des barques qui sont
constatés qui sont faites pour les
maisons c'est des barques qui servent à
naviguer d'un normalement
oui oui nous nous pouvons les déplacer
partout mais nous nous sommes
sédentarisés et ça fait 25 ans que nous
vivons ici c'est à dire que la
configuration du village n'est pas
toujours la même
en fait la structure et la vie du
village sont influencés par le niveau
des crues je me souviens en l'an 2000
par exemple c'était la creuse la plus
forte le filage s'est élevé et à bouger
maintenant le niveau des eaux s'est
rabaissé et la vie a repris son cours
normal ça dépend des crédits et les gens
essayent de se mettre côte à côte par
affinités comment comme on choisit son
endroit
lui nous rassemblons par famille
cette maison c'est celle de mon frère
nous sommes deux frères nous sommes deux
conducteur de bateau avec nos deux
familles nous disposons de sept bateaux
bus et aux alentours ce sont les barques
deux cousins de voisins
et mais toi tu t'es mis tout seul tu es
tu préfères être tout seul tu n'as pas
ta personne à côté de toi
c'est vrai ma maison est un peu plus
isolé que les autres parce que j'aime
bien vivre seul ou pas en tout cas
j'aime bien avoir le choix
mais des fois comme c'est un peu triste
d'être tout seul je préfère voir du
monde j'aime les échanges et ici il ya
une entraide une solidarité on aime bien
se retrouver en famille entre amis nous
retrouvons souvent pour boire un verre
et discuter
tu as choisi d'avoir le soleil toute la
journée il y en a qui sont tournés dans
l'autre sens parce que c'est un choix ou
est-ce que comment ça se passe
j'ai demandé des conseils auprès de
spécialistes pour poser les fondations
de ma maison et finalement je les fait
en accord avec les énergies positives
ah d'accord c'est quoi le feng shui et
ben on se sent bien dans ta maison
très bien
je serais bien resté chez toi
mais c'est pas possible on encore y
aller
et ça valait vraiment le coup parce que
c'était une journée extraordinaire
[Musique]
bon ce matin j'ai bien dormi je me sens
en bonne forme plus à l'aise que jamais
en pleine forme ce matin
je crois que mon pneu avant je les faire
gonfler et je pense qu'en fait il est
crevé démontage des changements en
direct
[Musique]
je sais qu'il ya très belles plages donc
je vais finir mon voyage sur la mer de
chine à la fraîche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même quelque chose la mer de
chine arrive en mobylette sur la mer de
chine j'ai comme ça
c'est joli hein
voici un peu de monde
donc
vous voulez boire un verre inverse
pourquoi pas oak est inquiet udraw
l'idée est en vacances ici non on est là
pour un mariage c'est son mariage
you son mariage félicitations
et vous aimez cet endroit j'aime
beaucoup
pourquoi vous n'aimez pas c'est son
droit
mais s'il retrouve son petit un peu
terne tu vois surtout pour prendre des
photos ce sable du sable noir de
[Musique]
temps en temps
c'est bien trop polluer c'est trop seul
vous avez des tatous les lunettes de
soleil vous êtes avons dans la mode non
non
j'essaie de devenir mannequin mais il
est pas fait pour être mannequin il est
beaucoup trop petit mais trop petit pour
être mannequin
you are de force vous êtes les premiers
que je rencontre ici qui parle si bien
l'anglais
on essaye on essaye tu vois on air on
aime parler avec les gens comme toi les
gens qui voyagent car on s'enrichit en
discutant avec des gens comme toi
mais j'avais déjà voyagé à l'étranger
oui on voyage et on adore les gens de
différents pays de différentes langues
où êtes vous allé en europe par exemple
n'ont pas encore en vacances c'est trop
cher là-bas c'est trop cher c'est trop
cher avec je ne peux pas y aller mais
les états unis c'est cher aux tirs non
aux états unis je ne crois pas
mais alors comment vous êtes-vous connu
à settat femmes mais nous sommes
rencontrés sur internet vous vous êtes
rencontrés sur internet
et nous nous sommes vus dans le nord du
pays comment ça c'est fait alors
vu son profil sur internet oui sur
facebook qu'on s'est vus en photo et
voilà quoi
c'est incroyable alors vous avez chatté
sur le net oui beaucoup de gens font
comme ça
beaucoup de gens font ça vraiment
mais vraiment
à quel beau couple moderne
le
cas
[Musique]
voilà je voudrais m'approcher v les
bateaux de pêche et je tourne
[Musique]
on peut monter
c'est faux il ya du monde partout c'est
en train de refaire les filets
c'est un seul filet que vous réparez la
mamie tu vois pas qui des petits trous
partout ici on vit uniquement du
rapiéçage des filets de pêche on gagne
45 milles de la journée pour ce travail
vous êtes des femmes de marins non ici
il ya beaucoup de célibataires mais il
ya aussi des femmes mariées à des
pêcheurs alors vous parlez de quoi quand
vous êtes entrevue tu sais ici on ne
parle que d'histoires d'amour tu veux
parler d'amour viens t'asseoir
[Musique]
à l'amour c'est le sujet le plus
important c'est ça
alors toi si tu aimes un
jeu prend les affaires et j'étais si je
pars avec toi
mais je suis en mobylette c'est pas très
confortable même si tu es à pied je te
suis
je t'aime
elle invite à manger un petit morceau
c'est parfait c'est le bon moment alors
poisson forcément
c'est difficile les baguettes les amis
c'est correct
je fais ça bien goode
[Musique]
et les hommes ils mangent pas les hommes
ils ne sont bons qu'à faire l'amour
comment on passe une soirée quand on se
rend compte la première fois qu'est ce
qu'on fait on va boire une bière on va
danser comment ça se passe
on fait l'amour
allez bye a vu balle et
c'est parti mais pourquoi ça bouge je
suis pas du tout à l'aise là dessus
quand ça se fait
ce terrible ça tu ridicule
[Musique]
ok
le
enfin sur des arrivées
à rio de janeiro
[Musique]
bon ici se termine mon voyage au vietnam
on peut aller en mobylette là sur la
plage
le rêve les gars
on privilèges dans un pays où la
mobylette est omniprésente j'ai vu qu'il
ya les vendeurs de glace qui roule sur
la plage ans de disette alors c'est ce
faire la même chose c'est si rare
d'avoir le droit de rouler sur une plage
je vais pas me gêner
ça c'est le
luxe suprême
[Musique]
j'ai bien mérité le troquet à celle de
mobylettes ou un transat
[Musique]
il ya plein de marchands ambulants comme
partout au vietnam ils font vraiment
partie de la société ce soit sur la
plage ou dans les villes vendent de tout
c'est l'économie de la débrouille sans
ces petits marchands ambulants le
vietnam ne serait pas le vietnam la
hyène marchands de lunettes de soleil et
luc hees qui vend à l'uni vent des épis
de maïs alors qu'est ce que c'est
maintenant des tee-shirts c'est juste
une façon survivre en faisant les petits
métiers ils n'ont pas le choix ah oui
qu'est ce qu'ils vont ticket de loto ah
les fameux tickets de loto c'est pas
trop comment ça marche ça d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qu'on peut gagner ça coûte
quoi 10000 30 centimes d'euro et on peut
gagner un milliard
500 millions de dôngs soixante mille
euros c'est à dire une fortune ici est
arrive à gagner combien on vendant des
tickets de loto
environ 30 à 40 milles donc ça dépend
des jours moins d'un euro par jour
[Musique]
tu es marié
non tu sais pour se marier il faut
beaucoup d'argent mais un jour peut-être
pour le moment je viens avec des copains
et jed financièrement ma grand mère qui
est à la campagne il faut marcher
beaucoup pour mon éthique et oui il faut
marcher beaucoup et longtemps et quand
je n'arrive pas à vendre je peux marcher
très loin alors pour rentrer manger il
m'arrive de me payer une mobylette taxi
ou un cyclo-pousse
quand tu prends un taxi pour rentrer là
où tu habites
ça il doit plus rester grand chose après
quand j'ai marché loin pour entrer ça
peut me coûter jusqu'à 5000 dont et
comme je n'ai pas beaucoup d'argent je
me débrouille je propose un chauffeur de
mobylettes ou de cyclo-pousse de les
payer en tickets de loto je fais un
échange je donne un ticket à 10000 et il
me rembourse 1 1000 dons s'il n'accepte
pas je rentre alors à pied et j'essaie
de vendre mes derniers billets
est-ce que tu serais prêt à échanger un
billet avec moi contre quelque chose
eh ben si tu me ramènes chez moi je te
donne un billet est une donne 5000 donc
non 5000 je vais pas donner 5000 tu me
donnes un ticket je vais pas traîner
chez toi aujourd'hui je crois que c'est
toi qui a gagné le gros lot moi j'ai
fini mon voyage
si tu veux je vais pas te ramener avec
la mobylette mais si tu veux toi je te
donne la mobylette et tu rentres avec
chez toi
sama merci merci beaucoup merci ok on
fait comme ça c'est toi qui a gagné loto
aujourd'hui
avec la mobylette qu'est ce que tu vas
faire avec
cette mobylette je vais la garder ici
avec moi j'avais d'abord vendre tous mes
tickets de loto et ensuite je rentrerai
chez moi la campagne rejoindre ma
grand-mère et j'utiliserai la mobylette
pour exercer un nouveau métier je
pourrais faire du transport et je vais
essayer de venir les voir comment tu
t'appelles tonnes par mois c'est
françois aymé tu sais quoi je suis très
content très content de te donner un
mobile est à toi c'est la meilleure
chose que je puisse faire
bon bah c'est bien by
tu peux y aller
moi qui n'y croient pas
ok
ok je pense que c'est quand je vais
partir qu'il va comprendre que je lui ai
donné asile soulève hockey
[Musique]
oh là là je suis passé aux eaux
il faut qu'ils reviennent avec mon
casque
et au cash